[Musique]
un matin de juillet dans un fjordoenland
nous sommes avec Ito ex-pêcheurs
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on arrive près de capucilly
c'est difficile à prononcer ou c'est
difficile à prononcer voilà c'est un
c'est une tout petit village de
42 habitants c'est vraiment perdu au
fond au fond d'un fjord à 2h 2h30 de
bateau de nous la capitale du Groenland
et là on va passer quelques jours c'est
un endroit franchement extraordinaire
on a l'impression que la vie la nature
rien n'a bougé ici depuis des
millénaires et pour commencer notre
voyage des clubs pêcheurs franchement je
voyais rien de mieux c'est comme si on
était dans un grand grand bol avec plein
de glaçons dedans c'est assez étonnant
tout entouré de montagne ah bah là on
est
là on est au bout du bout on est on est
dans un rêve il y a des glaçons c'est
d'abord des glaçons ensuite moi j'ai
qu'une envie c'est de voir les iceberg
c'est à dire les glaçons qui font
peut-être à peu près une dizaine de
mètres de hauteur c'est extraordinaire
franchement
plus on progresse à l'intérieur du fjord
plus les glaçons et les petits icebergs
se multiplient
et la navigation va devenir de plus en
plus délicate
itou a demandé à Christian qui nous
accompagne lui aussi à capiscillite
d'être son copilote
certains morceaux de glace sont
transparents
on n'arrive même pas à les voir
si on percute l'un d'entre eux ça risque
d'exploser le problème c'est qu'on
a vu attention parce qu'en fait on ne
voit pas toujours et ils vont pas s'en
prendre un c'est 10% au dessus et 90 au
dessus
[Musique]
on peut à peine leur parler là par
exemple
ça passe à droite et à gauche
il faut être très concentré
malgré le danger parce que c'est un vrai
danger il y a une incroyable bonne
humeur il y a une ambiance incroyable
ils sont hyper concentrés mais ils
arrêtent pas de rigoler bon maintenant
Bertrand je vais vous chanter une
chanson je n'ai que de la glace pour toi
et la chanson c'est
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire Christian je
vais essayer de récupérer un peu de
glace pour quoi faire
boire un verre
mais la première à récupérer de la glace
c'est Pierre Marie la femme dit tout
c'est de la glace pure c'est ça oui
c'est ce qu'il y a de meilleur pour nos
boissons
[Applaudissements]
il y a une chose
2h30 il faisait un froid de canard à
peine 5 degrés et là et là c'est
incroyable il doit faire 10 15 ou 18
degrés c'est un autre monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est un peu le goût d'ici
[Musique]
après avoir traqué avec nos nouveaux
amis groenlandais il est temps de
reprendre notre route
est-ce qu'on arrive bientôt
5 minutes du paradis
le paradis secret
ons bleus avec des palmiers mais il y a
aussi ici et en plus l'ambiance n'est
pas moins bonne
[Musique]
au fond du fjord 4 cabanes en bois que
itou a construit lui-même il y accueille
des amoureux de la nature sauvage des
randonneurs et des pêcheurs
[Musique]
nous rejoignons la cabane qui tout nous
a réservé première impression un vrai
goût de bout du monde et un décor
absolument unique
[Musique]
alors
là c'est du 5 étoiles luxe pour nous
franchement on a l'habitude des cabines
un peu rustiques un peu rudimentaires
mais là c'est
de l'autre côté de la baie le petit
village de pêcheurs de capacité mais
avant d'aller le visiter nous préférons
nous équiper et partir à la pêche
[Musique]
sur le chemin une première surprise nous
attend
[Musique]
on est au mois de juillet ici il y a des
cèpes et un foison des cèpes que l'on
appelle aussi bolaire arctique et ici
ils sont tous comestibles le voyage
gastronomique commence avec les cèpes on
n'a pas pêché un poisson mais déjà
trouvé la accompagnement reste
maintenant à aller pêcher le plat
principal après 45 minutes de marche
nous atteignons la fameuse randonnée des
7 lacs des lacs d'eau douce reliés par
de larges et tumultueux torrents les
mouches sont avec nous un bon indice
pour la présence des salmonidés
nous commençons avec cette cuillère sur
la partie la plus calme de la rivière
déjà cassé super
[Applaudissements]
mais tu sais
c'est la pêche
et puis on a souvent commencé pas
terrible pas terrible bien un moment où
ça décolle en tout cas j'ai hâte que ça
décolle je vais un peu plus loin et il y
a de nouveau
la rivière qui jette dans le lac un peu
plus loin je vais tenter ma chance là
[Musique]
en fait avec une cuillère de 3
et on les excite et là j'ai carrément
l'impression d'avoir pris un caillou
tellement c'était
j'ai l'impression voilà que ça bougeait
pas c'était puissant oh je l'ai eu je
vais rejoindre Bertrand j'ai atelier mon
frère et j'espère que tu as fait pour
l'avoir
sublime
magnifique superbe
c'est un article tu crois très très bel
article
bravo
un peu moins sur les côtes de repos j'ai
lancé
du Groenland
Pascal a trouvé le spot un trou d'eau
profond derrière une petite cascade
c'est là que les ongles prennent une
pause avant de remonter frayer
mais il ne semble plus disposer à mordre
alors nous essayons ailleurs
déjà une demi-journée de pêche un seul
poisson
juste avant de partir Pascal pêche son
deuxième mais cela lui a coûté cher
dans ce trou là mais bon il y a de la
casse
ou bien casser ma canne
le deuxième ça fait trois heures qu'on
galère avec Bertrand c'est une journée
très difficile
j'ai perdu j'ai perdu à une épuisette je
vais me casser ma canne
on l'a perdu je sais pas combien
peut-être 5 6 cuillères tous les deux
difficiles de reprendre la pêche quand
même
pour l'instant c'est un
sublime endroit
mais le poisson est tellement tellement
au rendez-vous peut-être on attendait
trop peut-être au fantasmé un peu trop
on nous avait dit qu'il y avait du
poisson et en fait
il y en a peut-être mais il mord pas
tellement mais bon c'est la première
journée parfois la première journée
c'est pas c'est pas une excellente
journée donc il faut surtout pas
désespérer et il faut continuer et on va
y arriver évidemment
pose ta cuillère elle va elle va onduler
toute seule et là en général ils sont
carrés dans les coins là et là
Bertrand décide de faire quelques
lancers les derniers de la journée au
cas où
[Applaudissements]
cela n'a rien donné fini pour
aujourd'hui petite déception mais elle
est de courte durée car ce soir voici le
menu
[Musique]
artichat
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
première journée
bah non
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que c'est bon
en été les nuits sont courtes au
Groenland à peine quelques heures
le petit village de capicidit nous
intrigue ce matin il est tout juste 7
heures nous décidons d'aller y faire un
tour
une trentaine de maisons traditionnelles
tout en bois
en été la population grimpe jusqu'à 70
habitants
ce matin nous ne croisons personne
mais nous avons d'autres projets
[Musique]
ça y est
on est paré on va aller sur la randonnée
des 7 lacs ou parit-il il y a un saumon
endémique
nous a dit le spot il y a un spot c'est
on remonte la rivière et c'est juste au
moment où on arrive sur le lac que les
points sont c'est pas une science exacte
bien sûr il nous a dit avec de la
ondulente ma foi on va essayer le
dernier des 7 lacs le voici juste avant
que la rivière ne se jette dans le fjord
c'est ici sur quelques mètres entre la
rivière et le lac là où l'eau semble
plus calme qu'il serait possible
d'attraper ce fameux saumon endémique ce
matin nous ne sommes pas seuls les
enfants du village qui connaissent le
coin pêche déjà depuis une bonne heure
mais ils n'ont toujours rien attrapé et
nos premiers lancés ne donnent à rien
non plus
les minutes passent de longues minutes
quand soudain
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quelle beauté
c'est une merveille bravo 2017
unique
là c'est un saumon et puis une ambulance
noire
incroyable comme quoi tu peux t'arriver
[Applaudissements]
et là il y a un spot ça fait plusieurs
fois qu'on essaye et la boum
ça a mordu dans les enfants qui sont à
côté ils ont rien et voilà parfois un
peu plus de chance que les autres
2 kilos et demi à bout de bras une prise
magnifique mais ce sera la seule de la
journée
[Musique]
ce soir dîner de fait à la cabane cela
commence par cet on tombe l'article
pêcher la veille cru mariné une simple
préparation à base d'huile d'olive de
citron et de ciboulette
[Musique]
forcément ici c'est un autre goût mais
déjà le goût est exceptionnel
[Applaudissements]
alors
c'est la même préparation que d'habitude
ciboulette sel poivre un petit trou un
petit trou mais je ne sais pas c'est un
goût différent de des autres articles il
y a un truc qui est étonnant aussi c'est
la la couleur de la chair espèce de rose
soyeux c'est rarement vu une couleur
pareille on est dans un fjord là c'est
le lot de mer et juste à côté c'est une
cascade de douche et le poisson il va
entre les deux donc c'est ce mélange de
de mer et de fleuves
qu'on retrouve dans ce groupe
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce soir nous recevons nos amis à dîner
il nous reste encore un nombre le beau
saumon du jour
et une poignée de cèpes que nous allons
partager
vous avez pris un saumon
est-ce que j'ai les magnifiques
et si c'est l'unique rivière ou les
saumons remontent après avoir pondu
leurs œufs dans le lac
de tout le Groenland de tout le
Groenland c'est la seule rivière
vous voyez ça c'est très simple
c'est très rouge c'est la preuve que le
saumon est en excellente santé
ce saumon local 100% naturel nous allons
bien sûr le déguster avec Christian et
sa famille gars qui vient de nous
rejoindre
papillote on rajoutera juste après qu'on
s'est traduit mais mi-cuit bien sûr un
peu de sel de poivre d'huile d'olive
peut-être un petit boulette le temps de
la cuisson nous faisons goûter à nous
inviter l'ombre l'Arctique mariné pour
une gars qui est d'origine inuite c'est
une première
n'est jamais goûté comme ça
et
donc ton grand-père était chasseur
pêcheur
oui sa famille connaissait un endroit
très spécial où il attrapait beaucoup
d'ombre l'article
[Musique]
donc dans votre famille vous avez pour
habitude de manger le saumon seulement
fumé pas comme ça pas comme nous non
donc pour vous c'est une première c'est
votre première fois oh c'est incroyable
on est en face de nous une groenlandaise
qui va manger un carpaccio pour la
première fois
qu'est-ce que tu en penses
c'est vraiment bon je ressens toutes les
saveurs dans ma bouche
c'est vrai que c'est un goût différent
du saumon fumé
oui c'est différent
je pense que la cuisson ça sent vraiment
bon
ça sent vraiment incroyablement bon on
va mettre un tout petit peu d'huile
d'olive
juste un peu comme ça c'est ce que vous
appelez un tout petit peu vous les
Français
[Rires]
vous pouvez en rajouter vous-même du sel
la ciboulette
un peu de ciboulette
voilà
je crois que
je crois que le bonheur est dans le plat
quand même
ouais c'est parfait
c'est un peu cru à l'intérieur il y en
août
Pascal est même prêt à manger les arêtes
ça sent vraiment bon
[Musique]
c'est le meilleur saumon c'est le
meilleur saumon que j'ai mangé de ma vie
et c'est vrai que c'est meilleur que
l'article char c'est meilleur que la
truite et on continue avec du produit
local les champignons oui ils ont été
cueillis ce matin par toi et moi
[Musique]
le lendemain une nouvelle pêche nous
attend dans le fjord
on fait une pêche
visiblement c'est en très peu de temps
et c'est vraiment à côté à côté juste à
une centaine de mètres du rivage la
morue ou cabillaud a failli disparaître
à cause de la surpêche industrielle elle
est aujourd'hui de retour et en masse il
n'y a rien de technique
il va juste au fond
5 4 3 2 1
j'ai parlé trop vite
tu as perdu
technique d'une grande simplicité mais
en fait apparemment les techniques les
plus simples sont pas forcément les plus
simples à réaliser autour de Bertrand
qui quelques secondes après faire un
autre poisson
mais celui-là ne va pas se décrocher
le premier cabillaud de Bertrand le
premier cabillaud du Groenland ça fait
plaisir
félicitations merci merci tout tu as
réussi mais c'est grâce à toi
oui ça y est mais c'est fou
superbe bon écoute voilà ma première
effectivement c'est un poisson un peu
minute ici en moins de 5 minutes on
attrape donc voilà on a suffisamment ici
on pêche raisonnable donc on arrête là
un poisson chacun ce sera suffisant pour
ce matin
retour au campement pour vider les
cabillaud
et nous allons en profiter pour
redécouvrir des saveurs oubliées
[Musique]
quand on était enfant et qu'on détestait
bon détestait ça mais tu veux que je te
dise moi je ne déteste pas du tout
non
c'est vrai qu'en plus on reconnaît le
goût du foie de morue mais en bien
meilleur
on reconnaît les yeux fermés
[Musique]
il est temps pour nous de rejoindre la
capitale tous ensemble
voilà donc en route donc on retourne à
nuque et sur le chemin et ben on va
faire encore une fois de plus une pêche
particulière le Red Fish
nous redescendons le fjord en direction
du sud
après une heure de navigation
il tout s'arrête au pied de cette
sublime cascade pour une pêche aux fish
on va pêcher ici oui
poisson rouge
[Rires]
à mon avis le Red Fish aurait paraît-il
une chair d'une saveur unique
même technique que pour le pour la morue
ou cabillaud
et qu'on va juste au fond là il y a une
trentaine de mètres
[Musique]
il faut qu'on travaille un peu non
mais ce n'est pas un raid fish c'est une
morue
[Musique]
[Rires]
on va pas sur consommer là il faut que
tu appuies ici
l'estomac pourquoi oui sinon il se
retourne il ne respire plus et puis il
meurt ah pour la pression
OK
fais la fête en fait que itoo nous
explique c'est que puisqu'on leur
relâche la morue et que elle vient des
profondeurs à cause de la pression il
faut un peu appuyer sur l'estomac sinon
là une surpression et ça peut éclater
voilà quand elle redescend
[Musique]
oui c'est un beau poisson pour Bertrand
pas de redfige non plus
nous relâchons les cabillauds l'un après
l'autre
le Red Fish ce ne sera pas pour
aujourd'hui mais tant pis pêcher dans un
tel endroit que l'on soit brodouille ou
non cela valait vraiment le coup
c'est la fin de la journée et nous
arrivons enfin à nous la capitale du
Groenland
nouk 18000 habitants
des maisons traditionnelles des
bâtiments modernes
et quelques imposantes statues
il y a aussi à nous qu'un restaurant
réputé nous retrouvons kissan c'est elle
qui chaque matin est chargée d'aller
faire les courses pour le restaurant
nous l'accompagnons au marché de la
ville en fait il y en a deux nous
commençons par le marché couvert
sur les talles de la baleine le
Groenland est l'un des rares pays à
pouvoir en consommer mais il y a des
quotas pour ne pas mettre l'espèce en
danger
[Applaudissements]
l'impression que c'est du avec un patch
de boeuf
et un petit coup de fer en plus je
trouve de faire saler elle a été pêché
il y a combien de temps
je pense qu'elle a été pêchée il y a
deux ou trois jours et quel était
exactement sa taille elle faisait à peu
près 6 mètres de long
c'est une baleine de minks la baleine de
mink fait partie des plus petites
baleines elle représente les trois
quarts des prises sur un quota de 200
baleines autorisés à être pêché chaque
année direction maintenant l'autre
marché on va aller au second peut-être
qu'il y aura du phoque j'en sais rien un
peu plus loin il paraît même que on vend
du morse ici alors l'intérêt l'intérêt
c'est qu'elle en fait elle fonctionne ce
restaurant fonctionne véritablement avec
la pêche et la chasse du jour donc en
fonction de ce qui trouve en fonction de
ce qui les inspire bah il compose le
menu du jour le menu du déjeuner et
celui du dîner
il n'y a rien
[Musique]
alors c'est ce qu'on appelle le capeline
voilà ce fameux petit poisson qui arrive
sur les côtes du Groenland Groenland
plutôt sud par
centaines de milliers alors sur une
saison très courte il faut pas les
louper et on m'a dit que ça appartenait
à la famille des salmonidés donc comme
les truite les saumons les artichages
etc
il y a un peu de viande de phoque c'est
pas très ragoutant ça fait un peu bouché
ça va être intéressant
[Musique]
et vous allez acheter tout ça
savoir quand aujourd'hui il y a même pas
de côté
ils sont vraiment présents et que c'est
pas il y a pas une pénurie de ressources
[Musique]
c'est pour la soupe
en fait c'est un plat traditionnel ici
oui avec le riz
en soupe en soupe avec des pommes de
terre des oignons du riz et c'est tout
et voilà c'est le livre à domicile c'est
assez pratique elle arrive elle est pas
sûr d'avoir du fuck tous les jours dès
qu'elle en trouve elle l'achète c'est le
circuit court ici il y a pas de surpêche
de surconsommation puisqu'ils sont quand
même combien je te rappelle tu me
rappelles combien sont les droits
50000 habitants sur un pays qui fait
cinq fois la France voilà donc il y a de
quoi manger
[Musique]
en attendant de goûter le fameux menu du
soir c'est l'heure du déjeuner et nous
avons prévu un pique-nique au bord du
fjord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bouillie à l'eau du fiorde c'est la
meilleure façon de préparer le cabillaud
nous rajoutons à peine notre petite
touche
pas trop un petit peu
mais je t'assure
[Musique]
on a l'impression que c'est une chaire
de langouste non je te jure j'ai
l'impression que c'est une chair de la
langouste
une morue à la chair ferme et délicate
qui a le goût de la langouste
un décor d'une pureté absolue
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas bien loin
du Paradis
[Musique]
le soir nous nous rendons dans ce fameux
restaurant Le kalal yarak et voici
enoungaque egelunda son chef et kyste
Stan gouak avec qui nous étions au
marché ce matin
[Applaudissements]
alors on est avec le fameux chef là qui
est juste derrière nous
ça a été donc
il a été il a été élu je crois meilleur
chef du Groenland plusieurs reprises et
alors ce qui est intéressant avec ce
chef c'est qu'il met en avant la culture
du Groenland quel est votre concept
utilisez de la nourriture locale
utilisez des ingrédients d'ici le plus
possible
au menu du soir du 100% local concocté
avec les produits du jour
quel genre de viande c'est de l'AG
Neau
donc c'est la reine du Groenland
[Applaudissements]
comme tous les soirs ce restaurant qui
révèle est réinvente la gastronomie
groenlandaise et complet
ici c'est le fameux caperlain
[Musique]
j'ai déjà mangé du poisson séché là
c'est du poisson séché entier donc ça
fait un peu bizarre mais j'aime bien
c'est c'est pas inintéressant
alors ça
c'est de la baleine séchée du foie de
baleine séché du foie
de morue
tu as beaucoup de goût voici maintenant
l'un des plats emblématiques du
Groenland la peau de baleine crue avec
sa graisse
faut la couper avec ce petit instrument
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un peu de la nourriture de survie
[Applaudissements]
je vais pas prendre un gros morceau ça
m'inspire pas trop après je suis curieux
donc j'y vais
[Applaudissements]
la graisse de la baleine j'adore en
mangeant ça j'ai l'impression que je
pourrais nager avec elle
et demain seconde partie de notre voyage
au Groenland nous atterrissons à narsac
direction la ferme duputac ou paraît-il
ou une rivière exceptionnelle
[Musique]
pendant l'année de brebis elle est
tombée amoureuse d'un
Groenland
et en même temps il y a un domaine de
pêche chez elle qui est paraît-il
extraordinaire les meilleurs du
Groenland même si nous sommes maintenant
à l'extrême sud du Groenland sur la
route encore des glaçons certains même
assez gros
on est pas passé loin là après une heure
de navigation nous arrivons à
destination
c'est toute la famille qui vient nous
chercher là bonjour Agathe
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est un domaine qui s'étend sur 10
hectares une ferme une grande bergerie
250 brebis une table d’autre quelques
chalets en bois et rien au tour
l'été il y a beaucoup de travail aux
champs et Kalista le mari d'Agathe est
sur son tracteur jusqu'à la tombée de la
nuit la petite famille Franco
groenlandaise qui fait tout elle-même
s'est installé ici en 2007
[Musique]
déjà une onzième saison dans un
environnement pas toujours hospitalier
[Musique]
les principales contraintes c'est quoi
les principales contraintes je pense que
c'est enfin il y en a beaucoup donc les
principales je sais pas mais peut-être
que la première c'est l'isolement
vraiment extrême en hiver on peut rester
plusieurs biens ouais plusieurs semaines
voire parfois à plusieurs mois sans voir
quelqu'un vrai d'autres que nous en fait
ça changement de vie hallucinant quand
même je pense que dans les pays entre
guillemets occidentalisés et urbaniser
même en campagne l'homme a toujours
cherché à dominer la nature et ici ça
nous rappelle un peu notre position dans
le dans le monde naturel en fait on est
on est qu'une petite partie de la nature
et c'est pas nous qui décidons
sur sa balançoire Inna la fille d'agate
et de Calista une petite fille pas tout
à fait comme les autres et qu'est-ce que
tu penses de cette vie que tu as ici et
ben c'est très différent de la vie
normale dans les villes quoi ça c'est
bien aussi d'être toute seule et d'avoir
la nature autour de moi et aussi d'être
avec les animaux et l'école comment ça
se passe l'école
c'est ma mère qui m'enseigne à la maison
c'est le matin tous les jours de l'hiver
parce qu'on était il y a pas de cours
tu t'occupes des animaux
que tu avais tu avais de la famille en
France tu vas souvent les voir
tous les tous les deux ans et demi à peu
près je suis content de mettre là-bas
mais j'aime pas rester trop longtemps
tu as envie de revenir ici
[Musique]
le lendemain matin s'est enfin le moment
de tester cette rivière dont on nous
attend parler mais nous n'en savons pas
beaucoup plus sur la technique de pêche
à utiliser je sais pas ce que tu en
penses mais on se fait une mouche et une
cuillère puis on intervertit exactement
c'est exactement ce qu'on va faire
visiblement c'est une rivière idéale
pour la mouche mais on s'assure la
cuillère quand même pour amener nos
notre minimum de quotas de poissons
c'est 5 par personne pas plus par jour
pas plus ça fait longtemps qu'on avait
envie de venir ici chez Agathe il paraît
que c'est un des plus beaux spots de
pêche du Groenland donc voilà il faut
pas trop
s'exciter mais on est quand même très
excité
après une petite heure de marche nous
découvrons la rivière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la rivière prend sa source au sommet de
cette montagne
elle passe par ses chutes spectaculaires
elle court ensuite sur 5 km à la fois
tranquille et sinueuse
pour se jeter dans ce lac qui est relié
au fjord c'est magnifique c'est
magnifique
on a l'impression que c'est un peu
Jurassic Park ici j'espère qu'on va pas
avoir de dinosaure en revanche et en
revanche il y a eu des ours blancs
parfois qui sont perdus qui sont
jusqu'ici c'est vraiment absolument
majestueux il y a un espèce de décor de
de du Seigneur des Anneaux
dans ce décor de bout du monde nous
croisons en chemin l'épave d'un avion de
chasse américain il s'est abîmé ici
durant la Seconde Guerre mondiale à
l'époque le Groenland servait de base à
l'US Air Force mais l'endroit est
inaccessible
75 ans après personne n'a pu venir
récupérer les débris de l'avion
[Musique]
voici la rivière
je pense que je vais être avantagé là à
la mouche sur en tout cas ce soir une
rivière par rapport à toi texte
nous allons pêcher la rivière en la
remontant un bon moyen pour éviter de se
faire voir par les poissons qui eux
aussi remontent pour aller frayer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là il y en a trois quatre qui sont en
train de remonter magnifique superbe
quand l'eau est claire comme ça c'est
génial très très bien
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas pour ça que je les attrape
et pourtant au bout de quelques minutes
alors
[Applaudissements]
doucement
premier le premier VIP
sublime regarde cette robe saumonée
magnifique
c'est vraiment un poisson d'une élégance
il est pas abîmé du tout un endroit
sublime c'est vraiment des plus beaux
endroits du Groenland c'est une chance
d'être dans un endroit pareil le péché
des poissons pareil
et en plus
avec une chair tellement savoureuse
[Applaudissements]
quelques instants après Pascal va en
attraper un lui aussi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là ouais je vais la sortir doucement là
je vais la fatiguer un peu
elle est assez jolie elle se débat
[Musique]
mais super jolie
pour tous les goûts un peu de cuillère
un peu de un peu de mousse et en voilà
ça fait quoi ça fait un quart d'heure
pour aller sur la rivière
un bel article chacun mais apparemment
nous nous sommes faits repérer et ça ne
mord plus
Bertrand passe alors au streamer une
technique de pêche à la mouche qu'on
laisse couler et dériver en silence
et effectivement ça marche
ma première à la mouche sur cette
rivière
voilà un streamer de couleur un peu
pourpre
très bel article char voilà qui a pris
très vite très vorace faut pas faire de
bruit il faut y aller tout doucement
faut presque ramper en arrivant et là
tac il faut aller très vite et voilà le
premier ici le premier la mouche
voilà je viens de perdre ma première
mouche
elle avec laquelle j'ai attrapé mon
premier poisson et a plus rien qui qui
marche enfin en tout cas la seconde
mouche ne marche plus je vais essayer le
streamer et à travers un poisson là son
second il me dit qu'il y a des trous qui
sont pas mal on va essayer ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà
bon c'est la première fois que je pêche
au streamer là j'ai essayé tout à
l'heure avec la mouche je l'ai eu une
donc effectivement d'après ma montre
tu fais trois lancer à streamer voilà on
agite un petit peu comme si on en est
des petits à-coups comme si le poisson
se allait un peu dans tous les sens et
la boum je savais qu'il était bien
accroché donc voilà donc il est arrivé
fatigué c'est pour ça que sur la rive il
s'est pas trop débattu il était fatigué
c'est ce qu'il fallait faire jouer avec
lui prendre son temps il y a une jolie
robe bien grise
voilà ça fait une heure et demie qu'on
pêche avec Pascal on a déjà quasiment
atteint notre quota voilà
moi j'en ai trois Pascal 2
attention
[Applaudissements]
pour les dernières prises de la journée
nous décidons d'aller jusqu'au pied de
la cascade
le poisson ne peut plus remonter au-delà
alors il vient frayer dans ses nombreux
trous d'eau
pêcher dans ce décor ferrique est une
expérience unique
encore plus quand sa mort
[Musique]
pour moi c'est le troisième de la
journée
[Musique]
Bertrand alterne entre mouche streamer
et cuillère jusqu'à cette prise un très
bel article char de 3 kg
[Musique]
une toute petite
on va arrêter là et on peut juste dire
qu'on a passé pour cette première
journée à études tac c'est une
excellente magnifique journée et je sais
pas ce qui va se passer demain mais
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment formidable
cette beaux poissons à nous deux c'est
largement assez au moins pour les deux
jours à venir
retour à la ferme deeputac
c'est la fin de la journée après la
pêche place à la cueillette ici juste
pendant les trois ou quatre semaines que
dure l'été pousse de nombreuses plantes
aromatiques sauvages
Agathe nous propose de la compagnie dans
son grand herbier naturel
et pas besoin d'aller bien loin pour
découvrir avec elle ces étonnants
parfums groenlandais alors ça c'est le
fameux thym groenlandais
en France ça ressemble mais
quand même assez différent
[Musique]
est-ce que ça ressemble à un retard
j'irai pas ça mais un petit Tigo de
violette d'ailleurs on devrait inciter
les gens à manger du thym comme ça parce
que c'est une saveur qu'on connaît pas
vraiment juste à côté d'autres saveurs
plus connues chez nous mais avec un goût
plus prononcé
un peu comme les épinards l'oseille
c'est de l'oseille enfin vous connaissez
l'oseille on en fait pousser dans les
jardins mais là c'est de la sauvage quoi
il y en a ici il y en a beaucoup parce
que les sols sont très acides ici on
trouve aussi des campanules réponses
délicieuses en salade ou en condiments
des orpins roses qui résistent à des
températures de -40 degrés utilisés
plutôt comme plantes médicinales et puis
il y a la plante reine de l'été
groenlandais l'angélique que l'on trouve
aussi dans nos régions en fait
l'angélique moi je connaissais pas
beaucoup en France on connaît l'anglais
qui forme confite et c'est une
spécialité du Marais Poitevin et du coup
moi j'ai fait des recherches un peu
angélique en fait a été importée c'est
vraiment une plante nordique elle a été
importée en France en fait au 12e siècle
des pays scandinaves et au Moyen-Âge
c'est devenu une plante miracle en fait
parce que apparemment enfin elle a des
propriétés médicinales assez incroyables
autant dans les feuilles les tiges que
les racines à partir du 18e siècle en
France
s'est développé tout un
tout un travail sur le l'angélique plus
dans la confiserie et les liqueurs en
fait on la connaît plus sous forme
sucrée
en fait ici il suffit juste de se
baisser pour se servir
ça c'est super bon c'est un petit goût
de
noisette
moi j'en mets dans la salade et en fait
on mange les graines quand elle commence
à arriver à maturité avant qu'elle avant
qu'elle tombe on mange les graines juste
les graines les graines de la renouée
vivipare une espèce de haute montagne et
des régions arctiques pour le dîner nous
rajouterons juste du TAS arctique sur
nos filets d'ombre un goût que l'on ne
trouve qu'ici
[Musique]
le lendemain pour aller à la pêche nous
ne sommes pas seuls il y a Ina la
fidagate et Étienne jeune ingénieur
agronome français qui fait un stage à la
ferme et s'ils sont avec nous c'est
qu'il y a une bonne raison
visiblement il y a ce soir ou demain une
bouillabaisse
et il n'a et deux missions c'est quoi la
mission Ina
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce que tu vas nous
montrer en fait la
sur le domaine les pêcheurs locaux
utilisent principalement la cuillère une
technique plus rapide pour attraper des
poissons dont on a besoin pour se
nourrir
il faut la suivre à la piscine
et si elle ne connaît pas tous les
chemins c'est parce que nous ne
s'aventurent jamais loin de chez elle
vraiment
des trucs dangereux
les actes des fois quand ils voient
qu'on est en difficulté ils attaque on
sait jamais s'il peut y avoir des ours
blanc
puis petite fille comme toi dans la
montagne ça se promène pas tout seul en
fait non
[Musique]
c'est marrant parce que elle est très à
la fois très à l'aise ici mais il y a un
côté un peu craintif
elle est c'est une petite fille à part
qui vit dans un monde à part mais elle
est très débrouillarde elle pêche
elle-même ses poissons qu'elle rapporte
à sa mère
le spot de pêche choisi par Ina se
trouve à une cinquantaine de mètres de
la grande cascade en aval
apparemment l'un des endroits les plus
poissonneux de la rivière
ici on l'appelle la piscine
alors il y a un peu de poisson
dans la piscine il y a des centaines
d'artichard
peut-être plusieurs milliers
les femelles viennent ici pondre leurs
œufs
dans cette zone de frais le spectacle
est impressionnant
[Musique]
en moins de 5 minutes il en attrapant
femelle comment tu reconnais à quoi tu
reconnais qu'elle est c'est une femelle
mais les ongles sont maintenant méfiants
et ils ne sont pas là pour se nourrir
en attraper un autre va prendre beaucoup
plus de temps
les minutes passent toujours rien et
c'est finalement Étienne qui a pris une
demi-heure de patience va réussir à en
faire
une jolie prise
un deuxième bravo
[Applaudissements]
maman t'a commandé combien de poissons
à tout à l'heure
[Musique]
ça fait un bon un bon 30 minutes que ça
mord plus mais on va quand même essayer
de pêcher avec Bertrand mais pas la
cuillère nous rester à la à la NAF
avant de reprendre sa canne Pascal
décide de refaire quelques images
sous-marine une occasion d'assister à un
exceptionnel balai aquatique
au même moment Bertrand s'est installé
sur le rocher qui surplombe la piscine
et ça marche mais la longueur du fil qui
risque de casser et le poids apparent du
poisson rendent la prise difficile à
ramener
vers moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
parce que là il y a du fond
S
[Musique]
le poisson a été pris par dessous
Bertrand l'a accroché sans qu'il ne
puisse mordre
autour de Pascal mais la mouche ne
marche plus alors il tente avec une
nymphe là bonne décision
[Musique]
voilà ça c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment ce qui marche
streamer qui a fait en fait dans
l'accrocher les poissons et là vraiment
ça a mordu donc là c'est une pêche un
peu plus intéressante on descend en
cours d'eau et dès qu'on voit qu'il y a
une petite chute et derrière une
académie pour faire glisser la la nymphe
et là je suis très content parce que là
ça a bien mordu comme ça c'est juste un
nain comme ça bah en fait que tu t'es
fabriqué toi-même ou non et la main
c'est amusant parce que en plus c'est
toi qui l'a fait de toi-même parce qu'à
la base c'est pas du tout une nain non
c'est une mouche c'est une mouche et tu
lui as enlevé les ailes et c'est devenu
une sorte de nymphe enfin c'est une
sorte de NAF ouais bon les spécialistes
vont rire
mais tu viens d'attraper il est là voilà
ce que tu viens d'attraper
plus tard dans l'après-midi nous
décidons de retourner à la piscine cette
large retenue d'eau où Vienne frayer les
articles chars et la surprise nous
tombons sur Michel un Suisse et François
un français et si tous les deux ont fait
ce long chemin c'est qu'ils avaient une
vraie motivation
parce que c'était le meilleur endroit
probablement dans le monde pour pêcher
l'articien il y a pas 36 endroits sur
terre on peut le pêcher comme ça en
rivière
très combatif qui qui vaut largement le
saumon
tout comme le saumon l'article char ou
Omble l'Arctique est un migrateur mais
aussi un redoutable prédateur
pour les pêcheurs d'où ils viennent
c'est l'un des poissons de rivière les
plus recherchés
[Musique]
en fin d'après-midi au bord du fjord
nous retrouvons Agathe et Ina qui a mis
son masque de singe pas content il faut
vider les poissons et si l'odeur attire
les chiens cela n'amuse pas beaucoup Ina
mais ce soir plusieurs invités dont nous
sont attendus la mer et la fille lèvent
les filets car il y a un dîner à
préparer
au menu de l'ombre l'Arctique en entrée
qui servira aussi de base au plat
principal
la très attendue bouillabaisse
groenlandaise
[Musique]
il est bientôt 8h et nous sommes chez
Agathe qui met une touche finale un
dîner qui s'annonce plutôt haut en
saveur
un repas gastronomique exclusivement
concocté avec des produits locaux
dehors 5 invités tous des pêcheurs plus
nous cela fait 7 Agathe aime recevoir et
elle a le sens du détail
[Musique]
et voilà nos autres
et voilà Michel oui Michel est un de nos
amis pêcheurs on s'est rencontré ici et
on est déjà amis François aussi qu'on a
rencontré ici on attend des Norvégiens
qui sont aussi des pêcheurs quel est
votre prénom
et vous venez de Norvège
et c'est votre premier jour de pêche oui
c'est mon premier jour de pêche
à la table il y a aussi un autre Michel
un franco-suisse et Harry le deuxième
pêcheur norvégien
c'est un nombre l'Artic
le vous connaissez bien sûr
et la plante en anglais c'est une rose
rouge
[Musique]
il y a un peu de piment avec de l'alcool
en danois on appelle ça Spitz
merci
c'est pas du tout du poisson fumé ça se
conserve il y a tout le monde qui
ressort tous les saveurs qui ressortent
à faire ça
voici enfin le plat que tout le monde
attend la bouillabaisse groenlandaise
avec une légère touche de teint sauvage
un plat au parfum subtil qui va faire
l'unanimité
[Musique]
on pourrait le faire mais c'est déjà il
y a déjà beaucoup d'ail c'est la couleur
de la bouillabaisse avec un petit plus
l'article
et puisque l'Arctique est à l'honneur ce
soir nous terminons le dîner avec cette
douceur parfumée à l'angélique
c'est bon
le lendemain matin c'est sous un beau
soleil que nous entamons notre dernière
journée de pêche à yputac
une journée qui va nous réserver
quelques belles surprises en attendant
nous décidons de descendre la rivière
qui vient se jeter dans le lac
voilà
au bout du monde
couru à peu près pendant 4 ou 5 km dans
la vallée un bon 45 minutes de marche en
tout cas elle se jette dans ce lac qui
lui-même est relié au fjord alors
normalement les poissons n'y sont plus
parce qu'ils ont mais ils ont remonté on
a eu l'info comme quoi il y a peut-être
quelques grosses spécimens qui
traîneraient alors on va essayer et
toute façon même si on prend rien le
décor est tellement grandiose qu'on a
bien fait de marcher jusque là oui
et ce matin nous ne prendrons rien ni
aux abords du lac ni en remontant un peu
plus haut sur la rivière
n'est qu'importe sous le soleil la
rivière nous dévoile toute sa
transparence et ses couleurs et oui nous
avions bien fait de marcher jusque là
[Musique]
en fin de matinée nous décidons de
tenter une pêche différente plus en
amont dans l'un de ses trous miraculeux
que nous venons de repérer
au Groenland on pratique la pêche à la
main dans certaines rivières c'est une
vieille tradition mais le trou est trop
profond
et c'est au filet que nous allons tenter
notre chance
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à la main mais c'est la pêche au filet
c'est la pêche aux filets voilà c'est
une première ici regarde je suis
descendu tout doucement d'habitude dès
que je fais un deux Guille pas les
poissons s'en vont fuis comme ça j'ai
mis l'épuisette dans l'eau et à un
moment
aussi sublime soit-il ces poissons
facilement pêchés seront remises à la
rivière l'un après l'autre
autour de Pascal qui va essayer de
descendre encore plus profond
[Musique]
pour lui aussi dès le premier coup de
filet et en quelques secondes un
magnifique article
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est vraiment une pêche qui permet de
d'être anti-moustique
après cette interlude au filet nous
reprenons la mouche et nous retrouvons
Michel notre ami pêcheur concentré à son
poste objectif de cette pêche à trois
notre déjeuner est très vite sa mort
[Musique]
20 minutes après le poisson à peine
péché se retrouve découpé en filet
simplement posé sur le rocher et mariner
dans un peu de citron et d'huile d'olive
avec une pointe de teint sauvage
est-ce que ça te
t toi qui est un pêcheur il mérite
est-ce que tu aimes ce genre de petit
rituel j'adore ce rituel et même un
étant pêcheur je l'apprécie quand il est
préparé par d'autres
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dernier déjeuner au bord de la rivière
[Musique]
ce soir c'est retour en France avec ce
goût d'ici qui nous accompagnera encore
longtemps et cette musique qui n'en
finit pas de trotter dans nos têtes
[Musique]